[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le mardi 21
novembre bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal
sur tv 78 tout de suite les titres de
cette édition c'est le début aujourd'hui
de la 33ème campagne hivernale des
restos du coeur plus de 13000 personnes
ont été accueillies lors de la dernière
édition dans le département les yvelines
où 27 centres de distribution sont
pleinement mobilisés notamment à plaisir
est les bénévoles ont assuré le
lancement tôt ce matin portrait et
nouveau président nouvel exécutif saint
quentin en yvelines vient de connaître
des changements une volonté affichée par
la majorité de droite
l'ouverture alors que quatre
vice-présidences ont été accordés à
l'opposition
l agglomération repartent elles sur de
nouvelles bases chronique dans ce
journal
enfin rappelez vous il y a il a été
inauguré en avril dernier le tout
premier temple mormon de france est
édifié au chesnay six mois après quel
bilan auprès des fidèles mais aussi des
riverains inquiets au moment de
l'ouverture
éléments de réponse à suivre c'est à
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire chaque
mardi dans le 7-8 journal le portrait de
la rédaction il est consacré à ce soir à
deux personnes une fois n'est pas
coutume
elles font partie de plus à des plus de
1000 à bénévoles yvelinois pleinement
mobilisés par les restos du coeur le 33e
quand la 33e campagne hivernale de
l'association s'est ouverte ce matin
plus d'un million de repas devraient
être distribués dans le département
portraits croisés au centre de
distribution de plaisir où officie 70
bénévoles s'est signé à camille lambert
dans ce centre des restos du coeur de
plaisir on se prépare à distribuer plus
de 2800 repas cette semaine dominique
fait partie des 70 bénévoles de
l'antenne cela fait trois mois que s est
engagé en faveur des plus démunis
étant à la retraite
on a quand même beaucoup de temps de
vivre donc
je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller au
resto donc je les ai rencontrés lors de
la fête des associations de plaisir et
puis deux jours après j'ai démarré
occupe de la distribution
essentiellement de la ramasse quand il
ya des
miramas à faire signer pour l'accueil
un travail quotidien pour cette
retraitée de 64 ans cette campagne
hivernale est une première pour
dominique et si son rôle et logistique
il est avant tout humain au début c'est
difficile parce que il faut vraiment
avoir le coeur bien accroché parce qu'on
rencontre des katas même assez difficile
certaines personnes qui qui qui
souffrent qui ont subi des actes et des
coûts de la vie de mauvais coups de la
vigne qui essaie de s'en sortir donc on
est là pour les pour les aider pour
discuter il ne serait pas bon parler
avec eux
des fois ils ont pas besoin ils ont même
discuté ont besoin d'un contact social
ce contact social c'est aussi rené qui
leur offre il s'occupe de l'accueil à la
personne et des inscrits les idiots
demandeurs d'emploi demandeurs
[Musique]
pari tenu donc vous simplement le fait
d'ajouter les réseaux avec mon fils
on les aide au point de vue alimentaire
nous on les aide aussi au point de vue
administratif
lorsqu'on va inscrire les gens on va
voir s'ils ont tous leurs droits
dire par exemple l'aide médicale d'état
ou la cmu c
les réductions transports toutes les
aider à régulariser leur situation
je recherche d'emploi on a des gens qui
sur un peu spécialisé dans la recherche
d'emploi faire un cv à établir un cv à
écrire avec les gens
franchir la porte des restos du coeur
une étape difficile pour les personnes
en situation précaire qui souvent
n'osent pas venir mais rené a l'habitude
de les rassurer
il a rejoint l'association dont les
années 90 et était même président
départemental en 1998 j'ai un engagement
très riche
beaucoup de gens disent un merci parce
que vous donner mais on reçoit beaucoup
enrichissant surtout je donne la moitié
69 ans donc ça donne quand même beaucoup
de
on a l'impression de faire quelque
d'être utile et de faire quelque chose
quand on n'est pas dans notre fauteuil à
regarder tes et je pense que ça fait
pour l'esprit pour la personne
d'important pour le moment près de 150
familles sont inscrites dans ce centre
de distribution de plaisir durant la
campagne elle devrait être 250 en france
près de 9 millions de personnes vivent
sous le seuil de pauvreté
les restos du coeur cherche toujours de
nouveaux bénévoles et sachez qu'outre
plaisir d'autres centres de distribution
sont présents à saint quentin en
yvelines à magny les hameaux trappe
la verrière et long cours ou encore aux
clayes-sous-bois plus d'informations au
www.restosducoeur.org on reparlera tout
à l'heure dans ce journal de solidarité
elle a débuté
hier maurepas organise pour la première
fois sa semaine du handicap plusieurs
animations pour faire changer les
regards jusqu'à samedi
vous le voyez notamment une
sensibilisation handisport au gymnase
des baissière demain après-midi ce sera
également le cas samedi mais en matinée
deux rendez vous autour de la musique et
du handicap portes ouvertes demain d'un
atelier et d'une conférence vendredi
toutes deux au conservatoire de la ville
jeudi enfin l'événement s'exportera au
ciné cette à elancourt projection de
patients film du slameur grand corps
malade
programme complet sur le site internet
de maurepas politique ce matin à paris
s'est ouvert le congrès des maires au
parc des expositions porte de versailles
c'est le 100e de l'histoire mais le tout
premier sous l'ère du président emmanuel
macron à cette occasion le président du
sénat l'yvelinois gérard larcher a
accueilli les élus locaux au palais du
luxembourg il y a tenu également une
conférence de presse mélanie poquet
découvrir le sénat ses acteurs ses
missions le palais du luxembourg reçoit
les élus locaux de toute la france
une découverte et une volonté d'échangé
à l'occasion du 100ème congrès des
maires il ya une certaine unanimité il
ya une certaine solidarité entre les
élus qu'ils soient du bloc communal
qu'il soit du niveau national les élus
les parlementaires effectivement nous
avons tous la même motivation nous avons
tous la même passion pour défendre nos
territoires
on est en attente d'un certain nombre de
réponses
il ya un climat de confiance malgré tout
mais on a besoin d'avoir un certain
nombre de réponses par rapport à la
ruralité particulièrement où le
président s'était exprimé sur sa volonté
de prendre en compte la ruralité et on a
beaucoup d'attentes à ce niveau là un
congrès annoncée comme tendues entre
représentants des collectivités le
gouvernement
gérard larcher président du sénat est
élu yvelinois apporte son soutien aux
élus locaux notamment sur la question de
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
taxe d'habitation et à des sujets et
voilà pourquoi j'ai proposé qu'on
travaille tout son sens à la mise en
place d'une fiscalité locale qui
permette de préserver le lien service
dans une commune où ils interco citoyens
élus locaux qui décident au travers
d'une fiscalité locale nous avons avec
sophie primas et mes autres collègues
sénateurs visite est quasiment toutes
les communes certaines deux fois depuis
le printemps
c'est l'occasion d'entendre à la fois
des interrogations mais aussi des
espérances des communes des yvelines
le congrès des maires se tient jusqu'au
23 novembre près de 4000 élus sont
accueillis au sénat d'ici jeudi
elle sans fin les pilotes des tensions
au sein de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines réuni il ya quelques
jours en conseil communautaire et les
élus ont voté en faveur de l
élargissement de l'exécutif à gauche
bonsoir nicolas kirillovitch bonsoir de
la rédaction de tv 60,18 cette ouverture
c'est une première depuis trois ans oui
et c est presque une mini révolution
dans ce dans ce monde qui est la
politique locale
vous le disiez c'est la première fois
depuis l'élargissement à 12 communes que
la gauche rentre donc dans l'exécutif et
obtient des vice-présidences regardez
plutôt à l'écran avec guy malandain le
maire ps de trappes devient 11e vice
président en charge de l'habitat
marie-christine le tarnec 5 au lag abus
en cours est en charge l de la ville
innovantes de demain un titre plutôt
original sur la forme
bertrand au lion le maire ps de magny
les hameaux lui sera en charge du d
hautement durable et de la ruralité des
thématiques qui l'apprécient et enfin la
maire communiste de la verrière nelly
dit tu seras en charge de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
là aussi une forme de logique est
respectée il y a donc finalement 14 vice
présidence à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
10 pour la droite 4 pour la gauche qui
devraient tous touché un peu plus un peu
moins de 2000 euros nets par mois et
quatre vice présidents de gauche donc
mais est ce que c'est vraiment un
nouveau départ pour l'agglomération
nicolas alors que les élus préfèrent
parler plutôt d'un retour à la normale
de ce qui était le fonctionnement
habituel avant l'élargissement à 12
communes
écoutez à ce propos guy malandain le
nouveau vice présidence président en
charge de l'habitat
ça permet finalement d'aborder les
problèmes de fond dans une cordialité et
une tranquillité
ce qui n'empêche pas la vie de chacun
qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis trois ans
où c'était extrêmement tendue les
adulations et cetera et cetera
chaque ville compte les gens les
habitants de ces villes en tant que
citoyens ont choisi leur mère et les
équipes municipales majoritaire ici ici
ça n'a pas lieu d'être puisque nous
gérons un territoire qui est qui nous
est commun et que nous devons continuer
j'étais bien continuer n'ont pas
commencé et continuer à promouvoir dans
tous les domaines et les enjeux grégory
sont sont évidemment importants sur sur
saint quentin en yvelines il ya
notamment à la ligne 18 du grand paris
express la ryder cup l'an prochain le
développement aussi du plateau 5les en
lien avec l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ou encore les
jeux
l'olympique en 2024 vous le savez saint
quentin en yvelines va accueillir
plusieurs épreuves olympiques sur son
territoire notamment vélodrome national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la gauche
revient donc en quelque sorte si je peux
me permettre l'expression aux affaires
au meilleur des moments
est-ce que ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour la droite nicolas c'est aussi une
bonne nouvelle pour la droite surtout
pour le nouveau président de saint
quentin en yvelines jean michel fourgous
pour lui c'est coup double il réussit là
où michel laugier son prédécesseur avait
échoué et ils cassent aussi pour le
moment en tout cas les idées reçues sur
son côté un peu clivant en tant qu'homme
politique
écoutez à ce propos le président de
saint quentin en yvelines jean michel
fourgous
vu les enjeux aussi bien économiques que
sportives que culturelles
la chance qu'elle a de travail sur des
projets comme comme l'université du
futur
la voiture du futur la sécurité du futur
enfin on a on a beaucoup de choses ici
et ça mérite vraiment ce soir ils ont
montré que que ça existe bien l'intérêt
général quand même surtout quand on
travaille on accepte de faire partie du
conseil d'administration type pilotes ce
grand projet d'une belle plateforme
d'innovation modèle en france quelques
doit être saint quentin c'est plutôt
rassurant
et désormais il reste à savoir grégory
scie concrètement les grands projets qui
concerne saint quentin en yvelines vont
avancer plus vite avec cet élargissement
si ce n'est pas un coup pour rien pour
assurer le coup justement les élus de
l'opposition ont demandé qu'une charte
de fonctionnement soit voté lors du
prochain conseil d'agglomération affaire
à suivre donc nicolas merci pour ces
précisions
c'est le seul temple mormon en france
inaugurée en avril dernier au chesnay
l'édifice accueille régulièrement des
fidèles une fréquentation semble-t-il à
la hauteur des attentes et un voisinage
qui a l'air plutôt rassurés après des
inquiétudes suscitées au moment de
l'ouverture il ya six mois premier bilan
dressé sur place par nicolas landry et
camille lambert
depuis six mois ils viennent se
recueillir dans leurs temples les
fidèles de l'église de jésus-christ des
saints des derniers jours appelé aussi
mormons sont de plus en plus nombreux à
venir ici au chesnay en moyenne près de
70 personnes par jour en provenance de
toute la france a les premières
impressions de nos fidèles qui sort
d'une anse bâtiment c'est bien
évidemment la la joie d'avoir un temple
beaucoup plus proche que ce qu'ils
connaissaient les contacts que nous
avons eus avec les voisins sont sont
positifs extrêmement positif
il y à des personnes qui viennent
régulièrement dans le jardin pour
apprécier le lieu pour se recueillir
également un regard des la statue du
christ et penser au christ lors des
travaux lancés en 2013 certains
riverains s'inquiéter des recours devant
le tribunal administratif des pétitions
signées aujourd'hui plus aucune
inquiétude et un climat d'apaisement
plane autour du temple
j'ai déjà visité dès le début si vous
voulez les l'ouverture comme on est
voisins on a trouvé ça magnifique
voulait c'était d'être eh bien on
visiter l'intérieur et doux oui c'est un
très beau temple
cela m'avait intéressé
on avait interrogé des gens qui nous
avait expliqué
les cérémonies les baptêmes tout ça
parce que vous pensez que les bâtiments
d'ailleurs nous le temple derrière non
pas du tout parce que vous savez ce que
c'est du tout une exposition
internationale de crèche sera organisé
du 13 au 23 décembre dans le centre des
visiteurs
un choeur interprétera des chants de
noël dans les jardins entre 18 et 20
heures après les restos du coeur place
une nouvelle fois la solidarité encore à
à plaisir une cérémonie symbolique mais
non a dénué de sens samedi trois arbres
ont été plantés dans le jardin de
l'accueil de jour de l'hôpital
gérontologique et médico social de
plaisir et des arbres faire aux malades
d'alzheimer par le lion ce club de
plaisir grignon
bonsoir michel de croix vous êtes le
président de ce lion ce club plaisir
grignon et bonsoir également aph à
jacques bérard on ça vous êtes le
directeur de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico social de plaisir michel de quoi
je me tourne vers vous pour commencer
quelle est la portée de cet acte
finalement la plantation de ces arbres
pourquoi offrir offrir ces arbres aux
malades on a offert ces arbres pour
ainsi dire amener une conclusion à la
construction de ce centre de jour
alzheimer auquel on a grandement
contribué depuis maintenant il a été
ouvert ya huit ans mais en fait la
sphère a commencé un peu presque vingt
ans c'était en 2002 les premières les
prémices du projet voilà dans le cadre
de
deux projets du lion ce club français
puisque le lions club international est
donc répandue sur le monde entier et la
france
est ce qu'on appelle multi district et
une avait une action nationale qui était
de promouvoir des centres de jour
alzheimer ouverture donc en 2009 on y
reviendra tout à l'heure jacques veyrat
ce geste représente beaucoup pour
l'hôpital le fait d'offrir ces arbres le
fait que le lion's-club offre ces arbres
oui alors c'est un geste très important
pour nous d'abord important
il faut le rappeler la longue cela nous
a donné 170000 euros il ya une dizaine
d'années ce qui tue presque 20% de
budget du bâtiment de l'accueil de jour
alzheimer
ensuite sur un plan symbolique c'est
très important que le lion de ce club où
d'autres acteurs privés d'autres mécènes
d'ailleurs participent aux soins donc
pour élargir un peu le champ puisque là
samedi dernier c'était l'alzheimer mais
les u11 que d'autres sections du
landskron nous ont aidés pour les
enfants autistes ou nous est toujours
régulièrement pour les enfants autistes
de saint cyr et pour d'autres sur
d'autres sujets aussi voilà la réaction
du lion's-club on l'a dit un qui ne
remonte pas à hier pour l' hôpital
gérontologique de plaisir alors
l'association énormément oeuvré pour
l'ouverture de l'accueil de jour ça
c'était en 2009 son nom d'ailleurs le
galion évoque une contraction entre le
val de galilée lieu de l'implantation de
cet accueil de jour et aussi tout
bonnement le lion's-club 1 le lion le
lion de galions évoque le lion's-club en
quoi ça important jacques bérard d'avoir
à côté à côté de ce côté médical le
soutien aussi de ses bénévoles pour
d'abord c'est l'inscription pour nous
dans la société puisque on ne vit pas en
vase clos
il s'agit d'une structure ambulatoire un
accueil de jour alzheimer ou les gens ne
couche pas sur place ils reviennent chez
eux ils viennent là plusieurs fois dans
la semaine ça ses premiers points
ensuite c'est pas le cas du lion de ce
club de l'accueil de jour alzheimer de
plaisir mais c'est le cas de certains
accueils de jour alzheimer on a besoin
aussi des bénévoles nous il se trouve
qu'il ya que des professionnels à
plaisir et à magny les hameaux ce que
nous avons un deuxième sans travail et
l'amour mais nous avons besoin aussi de
des bénévoles des associations
caritatives et autres pour nous aider
dans notre mission puisque
nos budgets sont de plus en plus tendu
une somme de plus en plus sur les
dispositifs tourné vers la société moi
donc une direction importante michel de
croix alors d origine de ce projet
d'accueil de jour remonte à 2002 à 2002
pardon ouverture sept ans plus tard en
2009 après beaucoup d'action du losc
l'om notamment des actions et de récolte
de dons c'est est ce que le principe du
lion's-club c'est de récolter en faisant
des actions c'est l'action
philanthropique finalement c'est
entièrement fidèle aux topics un neuro
confié ou lons cove est un euro donné il
n'y a aucun frais chez nous aucun frais
de structure et pourquoi avoir mené ce
combat justement à plaisir pour
l'ouverture de cet accueil de jour
justement parce que c'est ce
premièrement ce cet accueil de jour sous
dix c'était dans le cadre d'une action
nationale du lion's-club pour favoriser
les centres de jour alzheimer
premièrement et deuxièmement il faut
dire aussi que je suis ancien médecin
généraliste en retraite à l'heure
actuelle est donc ça m'intéresse
énormément qu de ferveur et libye qu'on
a eu pour le faire le principe était le
fait que l'hôpital était prêt à
l'accueillir à accueillir ce centre à le
construire même puis à le gérer
mais ne pouvait pas contribuer dans
lancé le projet d'accord et nous nous
avons donc relancé sa à 4 lyon ce club
c'est le lion's-club de plaisir mais
également 5e saint nom la bretèche noisy
bailly enough le chatressac arrêtons
d'accuser leur finalement et après ça a
été encore plus élargie puisque nous
avons demandé aux 17 mairie qui étaient
autour de contribuer à la construction
de ce centre 15 ont répondu oui et sous
la forme de 1 euro par habitant de ces
de ces communes alors cette plantation
d'arbres le pré 6 samedi c'était aussi à
l'occasion des santons du lions club
international
le lion ce club au niveau national c'est
plus d'un million de bénévoles répartis
dans 100 milles environ dans 200 pays un
peu plus de son pays
sur le globe voilà l'idée de mener ses
actions philanthropiques on l'a dit est
ce qu'il y aura deux actions organisées
par l'union ce club de plaisir gagnon
dans lequel de ses 100 ans
monsieur le directeur en a parlé nous à
l'heure actuelle nous avons cessé donc
l'action du côté sorte c'est notre
première nouvelles actions après
l'ouverture la plantation mais en ce
moment nous donnons pour les autistes du
centre de plaisir encore qui sont
donneurs en fait demeurait ainsi mais
nous continuerons à oeuvrer en général
un club à une action qu'on appelle notre
fil rouge par exemple là c'était donc le
centre de jour alzheimer maintenant en
ce moment sur les autistes
dernière question cet entretien je me
tourne vers vous jacques behra une
actualité qui concerne l' hôpital
gérontologique et médico social de
plaisir là on sort un petit peu du sujet
mais son utilité s'il va fusionner
bientôt cesser avec le centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot
également à plaisir fusionnons
avec jean martin charcot dans un mois et
demi un peu moins dans 40 jours l'équipe
de direction ont déjà partagé beaucoup
d'action en soignantes sont déjà
partagés la logistique des services
techniques l'informatique etc et mais au
1er janvier c'est une date décisive pour
nous puisque nous formons plus qu'un
seul établissement qui s'appellera ça
sans trop de choses fava renforcer les
collabos sur l'offre de soins ça
changera peu de choses dans l'immédiat
puisque les offres de soi sont
complémentaires
la psychiatrie côté charcot la gériatrie
le handicap la médecine aiguë la
réducation côté à gm s est par contre ça
va renforcer toutes les collaborations
dont soignante direction services
techniques services logistiques
merci jacques bérard d'avoir été avec le
directeur de l'hôpital gérontologique et
médico social de plaisir et merci
également à vous à michel decroix
président du lion's-club de plaisir
grignon bon anniversaire pour ses 100
ans du lion ce club international et
pour plus d'informations sur le club le
lions club de plaisir grignon vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et les
ventes annuelles de vélos font des
records elle dépasse le milliard d'euros
en 2017 c'est une première en france
pour équiper tous ces cyclistes une
entreprise yvelinoise a décidé
d'importer des casques nouvelle
génération et les fans de du tout
connecté y trouveront leur bonheur
marylène iapichino patrick jacques de
dixmude et nicolas kirillovitch un
casque qui vous parle la société e tc
basé à versailles importe en france deux
nouveaux casques connecter depuis
septembre jeux connectés et puis à
partir de ce moment là on peut y mettre
de la musique à vélo se couper du monde
peut s'avérer être dangereux depuis
janvier 2015 la loi interdit de pédaler
avec des écouteurs ou un casque audio
mais il suffit d'un casque de protection
avec enceintes intégrées est la règle
est respectée
les haut parleurs sont intégrés dans le
casque et donc ils sont pas sur mes
oreilles ce qui fait que j'entends le
sont de manière très claire
j'entends la musique c'est pas un casque
hi-fi mais j'entends la musique
et j'entends tout ce qui tourne autour
de moi donc quelqu'un qu'il
m'appellerait le bruit d'une voiture ou
le klaxon je l'entends tout de suite
plus que de la musique le système
bluetooth permet de téléphoner ou se
faire guider par un gps d'autres modèles
à venir proposeront également une caméra
intégrée et s'élargiront à une pratique
plus sportive et aux pistes de ski et si
l'on décide de sortir en groupe sans
téléphone tous les casques de la même
marque entre guillemets seront
compatibles l'un avec l'autre
donc je peux me balader dans les bois ou
en famille orville dans un rayon de 900
mètres tout en communiquant en full
duplex avec les personnes avec qui je
fais du vélo
donc ça c'est une particularité ces deux
seuls cas sur le marché qui faisons est
disponible pour l'instant sur des sites
traditionnels de vente en ligne à partir
de 240 euros il pourrait bien se
retrouver au pied des sapins des
cyclistes pour des sorties en famille
mais pas seulement
on communique comme ça dans le bureau on
vous a parlé à du festival saint quentin
d'ailleurs ne manquez pas demain sur tv
soixante dix huit nouveaux à dévoileront
le prix du public et un autre événement
cinéma qui se déroulait ce week-end
c'est le festival b à ba est dédié à la
bande annonce à bois d'arcy une
troisième édition qui a fait carton
plein samedi avec un cinéma la grange
complet camille lambert marylène
iapichino faire de la bande annonce un
art à part entière
c'est l'objectif que s'est fixé la ville
de bois d'arcy il ya trois ans avec le
festival béaba la ville compte bien
montrer son petit film résumant leurs
grands frères sont un vrai travail
il ya des bandes-annonces magnifique
des bandes annonces qui vous donne envie
d'aller voir un film des bandes annonces
qui sont des films en tant que tel et il
fallait rendre hommage cette a7 à cet
art qui a été oubliée jusqu'à maintenant
le festival est désormais bien installé
aucun fauteuil vide dans la salle qui a
même dû refuser une centaine de
personnes pouvaient lever doigt ceux qui
étaient là au moins une fois déjà venu
au moins la soirée était rythmée par des
thématiques avec un hommage à bourvil
les grands classiques ou encore les
couples à la scène comme à la ville
nous allons ce soir nous promener
pendant deux heures dans toute
l'histoire du cinéma et on va avoir 34
films et oui parce que d'une certaine
façon c'est vrai c'est dans une version
résumée
mais on voit 34 films etc ce qui
logiquement doit donner aussi envie d'en
voir d'autres et de revoir ce dont on a
assisté à la projection de la bande
annonce cette année 1 passe de l'autre
côté de l'écran avec l'intervention de
l'uqam à son un jeune réalisateur
français de bande annonce venu présenter
son métier
la clé c'est de donner envie aux
spectateurs et c'est de se donner envie
à soi même aussi c'est pour moi c'est
une passion et ses succès c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment stimulant et il
faut que ce soit donc
finalement c'est cette envie et que son
côté stimulant se traversent l'écran et
arrivent jusqu au public pour qu'il
vienne en salle où le festival s'est
poursuivi le lendemain avec son édition
junior au vu du succès de cette
troisième édition les organisateurs
réfléchissent déjà aux thèmes de l'année
prochaine du sport pour refermer ce
journal les yvelines ont engagé dans la
transat jacques vabre sont bien arrivés
à salvador de bahia au brésil après plus
de deux semaines de traversée
transatlantique 6e place pour le
versaillais tanguy de lamotte et
samantha davies pour initiative coeur
débarqué hier à la mi-journée leur
course à but solidaire va permettre de
financer les opérations de 25 enfants
malades du coeur
enfin le rambolitains à louis burton lui
a pour bureau vallée 2 a franchi la
ligne d'arrivée
ce matin vers 5h30 il décroche la 7e
place
la septième position de cette transat
avec sa femme servane escoffier
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal le
journal en replay est à retrouver sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 60,18 belle soirée à tous
[Musique]